see what that ex-facebook chief said
about what uh from the social dom his
name's tim kendall
he said a threat to democracy that could
lead to civil war
uh he's basically saying social media oh
yeah social media
is a threat to democracy it's
tribalizing people yes and it's
factionalizing it's gonna
he says it could lead to a civil war yes
agreed agreed because it's making us
arrange ourselves around world views
that are totally incompatible
with these empathetic triggers that
don't relate and then you start to think
that the other people are evil
yeah but you know the crazy thing is
it's the left
is the left doing so it's really funny
to have a conversation where you're like
you view the other as evil right
yeah because the left certainly says the
same things about the right but i kind
of view it like
light and dark bizarro and normal or
whatever yeah
the left is a bizarro reality right they
believe fake things like russiagate
they ignore real things like the hunter
biting scandal they believe the hunter
biden scandal is fake even those photos
so what do they do they have to censor
the information
otherwise people will realize they're in
bizarro world this is the good this is
the key takeaway from the hunter biden
thing
who is changing the rules of the game
that's how you know who's losing
yeah they're losing so they have to
change the rules of the game every
single time change the election we got
to change the election yep we're going
to do mail in voting to change the
supreme court
i love you know why i really love the
mail and voting thing if the democrats
just listened to trump they would have
been way better off now they're in
serious trouble serious trouble the
atlantic wrote about this
male in voting is a high margin of error
yeah and now the democrats have gone all
in on it
and they're going to get disqualified so
ridiculous so many
we're looking at people with like
cognitive dissonance and then they've
formed
now what's known as like the crazy alt
left these people that are like
just unable to see reality when the
emails are there and you see
oh the new information violates my past
belief and what reality is
it's actually there's a really really
easy way to break this down you want to
know how you're
in the real world you can say the clan
white supremacy and neo-nazis are
despicable and disgusting and so is
antifa
yeah there you go right the left can't
do that right
now they'll say things like oh i condemn
all violence say antifa
well anti was a myth right that's what
nadler said why is it condemn black
lives matter extremists
praise the good peaceful black lives
matter protesters they can't do it
okay i am not advocating violence i
don't advocate violence but the united
states was formed on a violent
revolution
and if we hadn't got we didn't start
they hadn't gotten violent it wouldn't
have happened
we didn't start the fight well we ended
it i mean whoever started it
british started a gunshot shot heard
around the world not civil war
it was uh it wasn't the bosses
the boston massachusetts massacre is
when it really started to take up yeah
when they when the british tried seizing
the weapons from the colonists but they
got off
john adams yeah they did and then people
started fighting back so
where am i listen listen police
brutality people are fighting back
i mean it's like i don't condone the
behavior but tiananmen square
could the people have overthrown the
chinese communist party without becoming
violent against them obviously not
because the chinese ruling
they're talking about fake news yeah the
police brutality narrative is fake
i agree with you it's different than
being run by a king it's totally
different there there
are instances of police brutality police
brutality is a very serious problem when
it occurs
and these cops should be arrested
there's also a problem with cops lying
to protect each other when they do
commit crimes
but there is not some widespread group
of like secret police who go around
hunting down minorities like they've
literally been saying
right there there were according to the
washington post tracking 13 unarmed
black men who were shot and killed last
year in the united states
out of 375 estimated police interactions
that is a ridiculously fake narrative
when a cop shoots somebody and kills
them
it should be investigated and we should
treat it very very seriously
i'm not a big fan of the idea of
qualified immunity and i believe we need
police reform i believe we need criminal
justice reform i believe the drug war
has failed
yes but to go around now saying abolish
the police dismantle the police
and we're defending ourselves because
you saw
fake news is not the same thing
defending yourself from the british i'm
not in a place
where i think that we need violence to
write the situation i don't think it's
that bad
well i mean look you look at these these
lunatics in in michigan well hold on
hold on
i do not advocate for violence either
however at some point
you need to understand that you're in a
burlap sack and you're either the
mongoose
or you're the king cobra and which one
of you is coming out of that sack and
that's what i'm starting to feel like
is like okay i don't want to have a
fight but like dude they're not stopping
like this thing is just keeping coming
at you it's like a zombie what are you
gonna
do this is this is the question i was
asking before and i said what do you
think comes next
if you have uh twitter and facebook
shutting down one of the oldest
newspapers in the country
because it proves joe biden is a lying
corrupt piece of human garbage
because they want him to win what
happens
when that lying corrupt piece of garbage
actually wins
and then does something horribly corrupt
and terrible and nasty they're not going
to report
obviously they're going to hide it
listen this doesn't prove it but it is
evidence
i'm saying if it does like i'm i'm being
more figurative and
and bombastic so what i'm saying is
if you're on the right and the
perspective of people on the right is
that
it proves it i didn't in my segment
actually said
here's the argument from the left
they're arguing that opportunity doesn't
mean he actually met them
but that's ridiculous so listen if joe
biden said i never talked to my son
about this
and then an email comes out saying i met
your dad and i work for barisma
sounds like he's lying right so inter so
media has been intervening the whole
time lying fake news
ridiculous remember when abc edited the
footage of trump to make it seem like he
was throwing the fish food in
seemingly ridiculous and innocuous
things that are so
paper towels or whatever yeah yeah it's
fake
fake fake so you're being lied to
they're cheating they're manipulating
and now they're straight up saying you
know what the new york post published
this story which is a huge expose makes
biden look bad
shut it down shut it down because we
don't know where it came from
no no that's what they are arguing
because they can't confirm how they got
it they're not allowed that's ridiculous
that's not your twitter set right the
the the story confirmed where they got
it they got it from the hard drive
of uh uh a repair man who was rep who
was given
the twitter terms of service that if
they produce a story without
it it was hacked information they
definitively said it was something it
was not they are lying
hands down lying the guy from facebook
who announced the censorship
worked for the democrats the dccc and he
straight up says we're suppressing this
so i'm telling you man from the
perspective of the right
i feel like we're sitting on a powder
keg and the only thing that can happen
is that it happens the powder kick go
boom
no the the uh no oh no
no the only thing that can happens is
that the democrats win they take over
a corrupt government ensues the cronies
continue enriching themselves while
selling out our government
and our country and our corporate and
our manufacturing base and that's the
end of it so here's why this is a really
big deal
we are on the cusp of having technology
that is capable of
silencing all of us automatically and
then doing it in a way
that almost can't be stopped and so if
the wrong
people get the technology they're able
to create what john rob
calls the long night okay it's happening
imagine you're
live in hong kong and you're a
pro-democracy person
you're definitely experiencing the long
night now
right they facial recognition track you
everywhere you go social credit scores
whatever
those people pro-democracy folks in hong
kong they're in big trouble
right what happens if that happens here
they have control of social media
they have control of our networks
communication technology
they can change the laws they can
implement their ai all of a sudden you
can't do anything on the net at all ever
period done
finished it's already happened to a lot
of people it's half happened to me but i
thought
luckily i could did you did uh did
enrique tell the story about mailchimp
i think so yeah they cancel everybody no
no enrique didn't have a mailchimp
he never he never had one and the
leftists complained and mailchimp
claimed
they banned him but he never had an
account literally
they lied wow to just say they did it
too
for clout yep we need some black mirror
dude we're building an alternate system
that's what the liminal order is
alternate system it's information
militia that's we call it
info militia is our job we serve our
members we go out we find information we
synthesize now the media is going to say
jack murphy's self-proclaimed militia
i'm not even kidding information doesn't
matter by the way
by the way being in the militia is part
of being in america yeah that's for sure
which is also what hung up trump on that
do you disavow militias he's like
these guys in michigan though morons you
know why
because they won who are you talking
about the guys the guys in michigan
wanted to kidnap whitmer or whatever
yeah
the court already ruled she she had no
power and the ag said she's done
and if they didn't do that like that's
why i'm saying like violence certainly
isn't the answer and these ridiculous
extrajudicial acts are not working
especially when you're winning in the
courts
so you know forgive me for being too
pessimistic on a lot of the stuff
i think it's possible that the media is
lying we know
that you said it well look who's
changing the rules they're losing
and maybe that's the case yeah maybe
they're trying to maintain this facade
of power but that's really being
stripped away from the inside out
and i've had so many conversations with
people that are saying straight up
they're not politically active but man
they're voting for trump yeah
i have not met anybody that they voted
for trump poor switching
i've seen the dnc people the trump gret
people
i've never met a person in the real
world who said i voted for trump and now
i regret it right not once
nine million democrats ditched the party
to vote for trump in 2016 and not a
single one is going to go back
you wrote a book about that i wrote a
book democrats are deplorable you find
it on amazon
five-star reviews over a hundred we
moving up the list
sales are brisk people want the story
you know why they want the story
is because it speaks to them and it
talks about their transition and the
experience of what it's like to become
awake and to get red pilled and to make
a move that was bold
it's hard to vote for donald trump after
you voted for the democrats you want you
know what the reality is
tell me the reality the reality is once
you see the truth
you are broken out from bizarro world
totally
every single person i've talked to about
how they went from
democrat to deplorable it's a story
about how they watched a video of trump
speaking
or investigated something on their own
brandon struck the reason why
facebook and twitter are desperately
trying to shut down
this story about hunter biden is because
it will snap you out of their bizarro
world instantly 100
joe biden said i did not talk to my son
about this
yeah well all of a sudden here's an
email right apparently that's not true
and there's evidence upon evidence
they're desperately trying to contain
this
yeah and they're losing it's a one-way
street the bread pill it's a one-way
ticket dude
it's a one-way ticket and more people
are it's happening tonight i got red
pill in 2007 about is when i started
getting all this information about 911
and like the
war in iraq and afghan and all this like
the war
military industrial complex and i tried
to go back to sleep
it was so hard to be there when no one
else
i felt so alone in the world that 2009
came around obama got elected i was like
i can just
rest easy obama's gonna fix it all yeah
three years go by
chaos begins i tried to stay asleep 2014
syria all of a sudden and and so i that
woke me back up
going into syria was a no-no you know
that and then from then on i just i've
had to
eat my way back into the mate out of the
matrix i saw i saw somebody tweet this
which i've been saying for years now but
somebody tweeted it and then somebody
big retweet and said look the only poll
you need
is that is that no one that voted for
trump isn't
and and like fewer people are voting for
the democrats that's all you need to
know
johnny rotten punk legend voted for
hillary clinton
voting for trump now right i mean tim
poole milk toast fence editor didn't
vote for trump in 2016 voting for trump
now
democrat to deplorable i believe it all
started i'm just kidding no but
but but it did we did have a very good
conversation first time i was on here we
had a conversation first time
and i went back uh checked the comments
afterwards and in the comments dude
there were like thousands of your guys
saying
thank god jack murphy's asking tim the
questions we've always wanted
to ask thank god he's saying everything
we've been saying in here for years
and uh when i saw the you know the one
with adam where you were finally finally
came out i was like man i dropped a
couple super chats in there myself i was
like hell yeah
well it's it's it's the it's the middle
east stuff yeah i mean i remember
earlier in the year when i was like
if he appoints tulsi to a security
advisor yang to an economic advisor and
gets us out of the war in iraq
like i will happily whistle a tune while
i go in and push that button down
uh it's not gonna yang i i think
went the wrong direction yeah he went
totally establishment and now i'm kind
of disappointed because he was he was he
was a voice of reason in a lot of ways
not that i think ubi is necessarily
a good idea uh tulsi gabbard i think was
also desperately trying to pull
bring people together as best she could
and she couldn't you know she wasn't
strong enough
but you know she's getting rid of people
strong that's why they silenced her
yeah she was but i mean she's a
progressive and she was really trying to
speak
to conservatives and trump voters and
everything and she had some conservative
endorsements too
but uh i think trump's got to do
something on the war on drugs
criminal justice criminal justice reform
was good yeah but the the middle eastern
peace deals dude
i remember when north korea happened
with trump and
i was i was like i was welling up man i
was feeling that emotion deep inside me
because i don't think people realize
what it means that trump crossed the dmz
into north korea right
it means the north korean soldiers try
grabbing south korean soldiers and
pulling them over
to like take them away and trump
willingly walked walked into north korea
with no security at all
with kim they smiled shook hands and
then they walked back together and i was
like
could be the end of the and now there's
there's murmurs that they're desperately
you know trying to figure out a way to
end the actual conflict i don't know if
it can happen yeah
but when you're speaking in the middle
east what's happening in the middle east
is a fantastic thing to talk about
i said daver boy on a middle east
specialist and he was telling me that
what's happened in the middle east is a
rise of a new nationalism
okay like these arab states they're
nationalist states they want to take
care of themselves they want to do
what's right for them and their people
and because of that it's the dismantling
of the globalist sort of empire
right and then in america that's what
we're fighting against too people on the
right
most people are nationalists or at least
anti-globalists
right and we want to just have a sense
of taking care of ourselves doing things
that make sense for us
in the world today and so when you see
this happening in the middle east it's
very similar
and it's going to strengthen israel it's
going to strengthen saudi arabia it's
going to strengthen
united arab emirates it's incredible
it's it's i
i hear you but it's not even it's not
even national globalist
it's authoritarianism i i have zero
problem
if we if we created some kind of one
world
government or society so long it was
built upon our
ideals yeah free speech constitutional
rights human rights
and then everybody you know had those
equal rights i'd be totally fine with
something like a federation
yes with a prime directive so i'll put
it this way imagine there is
a one world government but like the
states
the u.s is sovereign in its own internal
laws and decision making
and the international laws govern
between countries
we try doing that we do that right now
we have well we have all these super
national organizations that make rules
and things that are non-democratically
enacted and
that's what they don't like in the eu
that's the problem the problem is the
authoritarian imposition
of these rules if we had a liberty
based system of international
cooperation and agreement
but individuals were guaranteed their
rights
i love you tim but this is part of your
transition still i think
don't be totally nice about it i mean at
the end of the day what we've seen is
that unless you make the american people
the priority of the government that
governs the american people then the
american people gets i'm not saying not
to do that but i know but in that
circumstance you're trying to take care
of people
in this place in that place and be
everybody all happy i'm not saying that
you would say
the ohio i'm saying i'm saying if we
have
uh look at the laws of the states yeah
we have a federal government the federal
government isn't particular
i mean it's decently strong but trump
can't intervene in these states where
riots are going on
that's local rules yeah so those these
these states have their own jurisdiction
and their own laws and they can work for
the citizens of their states
they just don't want to so i think we
can have
international cooperation in agreements
but they're not being done right they're
being done by authoritarians who want to
enrich themselves
you wouldn't even have to have a global
president i don't think i think the idea
of a president's passe we would have
like a council of however many 12 to 30
people
or so we have the u.n artificial
intelligences that advise them and we
would have something like a
democratically elected
cis body of people these are great ideas
however i will tell you that the trends
that i've identified and people i talked
to identified is that this era of
expanding
is done this era of indiscriminate
expansion which we've seen is done
social media expansion nato expansion
world trade organization expansion u.n
expansion all that
finished and what we're seeing now is
strategic disconnection
and we see in that social distancing we
see that in social media erecting
barriers between yourself and the
network
we're seeing that among nation states
and we're seeing among tribes
so like this expansion era done so so
here's the council's
connection so here's a question then
what happens when one country
burns through its resources and is
desperate need for for more
well i guess we'll have to deal with it
on a case-by-case basis but if you're
saying that they're coming after my
resources then we definitely have to
defend mine right yeah yeah so war
breaks out
yeah i think the the one of the
arguments that
these like international organizations
have made is that all these free trade
agreements will prevent war
i actually don't think that's true i
think it causes destabilization
i think there's a way you can come about
making sure
it it it is seriously challenging this
is a phrase they used to have i mean
like i said before i went to the george
collins school of foreign service and i
studied
international affairs and international
economics and what they call that is the
embrace of death
and what they mean by that is let us
embrace you we'll trade with you
we'll give you our culture and stuff and
then hopefully that'll kill your
authoritarian impulses it'll kill all of
your human rights violations
it does not work does not work we trade
with china
it's not preventing a conflict with
china in fact what we've done is
completely enrich them they are
mercantilist nation who are out there
trying to collect as much money and
assets as possible
and here we are just with our deficit
just sending them assets probably
both because we've been able to unify
with mexico and canada in a way that
wasn't
in the past well trump actually fixed
that i think i mean
it's language language fixed it in a lot
of ways too being able to communicate
but i think the neural net speaking of
communication is actually going to push
things
towards an expansion so the borg yeah
well there will be no war
everyone's working for the for the
collective doesn't happen unless you
decide
for the collective but that that we're
breaking down into tribes i don't think
is actually
going to continue it does seem like
we're kind of
um uh you know imploding or in
it expanding yeah we're tribalizing but
with this neural net and the internet
uh it just we're so connected everything
i don't i don't think so i think
what's what's happened with twitter and
facebook and youtube is that
people can now express their opinions on
grand scales yes revealing which tribe
they were in or what ideas they held yes
normally the guy sitting in his kitchen
would would be watching cnn
and he'd go ah this guy's a [ __ ] but
who would he tell nobody
right so imagine this if we all got
neural link you know elon musk's brain
connection thing
and then clicked in to this like
internet where you can just think and
see what people are thinking whatever
they decide to put out
it would be twitter on crack it would it
would be like you'd immediately know
everyone you hate you'd learn all of
these things you hate about them twitter
it's like you could be friends with
somebody you know 10 years
like before twitter and you'd hang out
because of
your shared interests dude you want to
go to the game then one day
twitter comes out now that person says
you know i can't stand
pepperoni pizza and you're like whoa my
pepperoni pizza is my thing right and
all of a sudden you're like bro are you
an auntie pepperoni pizza guy you're
into pepperoni
dude and they start fighting and you
think tribalism is the natural
order of humanity yeah i mean so i got a
couple of things to say here
game a is the way that we've organized
our societies in the beginning small
tribes 30 150 200 people
and we've now extrapolated that societal
arrangement to where we are today that's
why it's not working
okay and the second thing is is when you
talk about social media being the thing
that's going to kill
us basically civil war whatever the
reason is is because it breaks down
social cohesion so we use narratives the
reason why we are in tribes
is because we have shared imagined
stories
shared imagined orders that we believe
in and we belong to
and i know in your imagination you we we
agree right
and when there's only one person you
telling you what that story is
it's very easy to have cohesion so when
walter cronkite is up there just talking
to the entire nation at night
everybody's watching him
he can tell you the story we all believe
it or maybe not but at least we have a
social cohesion around that story
we had one to many now we have many to
many right we have everybody talking we
have every story possible every
narrative possible
and so people are finding the narrative
that fits best with them
in their physical makeup chemical makeup
history
genes culture whatever whatever story
works with them
and so now you've got in your imagine
order your brain
you are now in a tribe with a guy that
believes that same story and so what
happens when there's more than one story
there's a thousand stories there's a
million stories
so now we have a thousand or a million
imagined orders and therefore now we
have a thousand
million tribes so it's it's a it's a
it's a language control thing it's a
it's a mental image thing it's a
imagined
this is you know imagine ordering your
brain now it can be
anyone out there if you just find the
one that feels right that just fits with
it and this is why they
create like fears of like aliens have
come or there's an asteroid they'll try
and scare the human race into believing
in one great thing because fear is an
easy way to create a narrative i mean
rallying everybody around a cause yeah
it would definitely be uniting if we had
if we had a common enemy like that
i was so surprised at the pandemic that
people didn't unite
more there was a brief moment yeah there
was a brief moment in march
where it almost felt like that where the
pandemic was going to be the thing
that like brought us together but it
turned out there was so much lies and
misinformation control and whatever else
that it just
by april that was done i got an idea
what if what if we work together to
stage a fake alien invasion
we can't talk about it already let the
god out of the time squid squid aliens
let's do it we'll put it on tv and then
it'll end all war
and conflict yeah what's his name did
that the war of the worlds
yeah oh yeah that didn't go wrong yeah
great radio broadcast from the 30s i
think
that was right the next show the next
show we just just
live we just play it live straight
totally straight 8 p.m and we'll like
we'll have the cameras go out oh no
what's happening oh oh
oh aliens oh we're being attacked by oh
no oh jack oh they're abducting him i
mean the crazy thing is there could be
aliens and we could be
in trouble so we should probably live
like that there could be an asteroid
that could smash into earth and destroy
it if we're not aware of it so we should
live like that
yeah but your solution to the asteroid
problem is a giant microwave cannon and
i'm talking infrared lasers
you're wrong i have no idea what you're
talking about water into the atmosphere
is a sphere around the earth and then
charge it with an electrical current so
it deflects the asteroid
no because the energy would still
transfer into the particles and then
push earth out of its orbit you're so
dumb try to move it faster to him
can you believe this or this this this
moisture this guy look at his shirt
away his social media immediately these
these moisturists are dangerous do not
link to the moisturists
he totally is i'm anti-moisturist i'm
starting a new group
right you know i heard moisturists nazis
definitely definitely do you do you know
what i was going to do you know
someone's military base on the moon
nazis you know that okay symbol that
people think is white supremacy
i'm not gonna make it right now don't do
it but if you think about it it's a w
for water wow oh my gosh
you have just definitely proved you just
called me out
moisturist no no listen you guys ever
watched the fairly odd parents
no negative they had one of the best
episodes to break this down listen
everybody
no listen i am going to educate you on
on important cartoons we got this
the fairly oddparents about timmy turner
who has two fairies who grant him wishes
so he wants a world where everyone's the
same because he's gonna be made fun of
anymore
so everybody turns into a blob and
somehow
they still find a way to form tribes and
insult each other
when they have no characteristics yeah
it's actually a pretty good episode
interesting for a kid's show
interesting it is the natural state of
affairs to have affinity groups
to have people that you like more than
other people and people that you're
committed to working with
and that you believe the same thing it's
common is that because in our
historical dna because it protected us
from
it is what actually helped us if you
read sapience which is not entirely the
best book in the world but this is a
very key point
it is what has allowed us to evolve to
this point is our ability
to organize around a shared imagined
order
something that's in our brains so it's
not only just in our history it's
actually
fundamental to our our evolution to
where we are to this point today there's
no
getting rid of it the myth they call it
the myth of what whatever you believe is
the shared ideal they call it
a myth so like religion or mathematics
or the wage gap
yes or the wage gap exactly so by the
way i write a lot about shared imagined
orders and the
fundamental myths of the left in my book
democrats are deplorable on amazon oh
look at that
on amazon tape with that i have as a
matter of fact and my audible release is
going to be
as soon as they approve it it's been
uploaded audiobook is forthcoming any
minute check my twitter feed jack murphy
live oh cool
go subscribe to my youtube page you guys
are watching this on youtube right
yeah oh my god go subscribe jack murphy
live we're going live tomorrow at 11am
rob i did not i'm not sleeping
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you